-Our next guest is an Emmy-
and Oscar-nominated actress
you know from movies like
"Do the Right Thing,"
"Fearless," and
"White Men Can't Jump,"
as well as the HBO Max series
"The Flight Attendant."
She stars in the second season
of "Your Honor."
New episodes debut Fridays
on streaming and on demand
and air Sunday nights
on Showtime.
Let's take a look.
-Have I given you the impression
that any of this is optional?
-I don't know why you're
trying to push me?
-Seriously?
Everything you know
about the Baxters, everything
you've seen them do, it --
honestly, it's just driving me
a little bat-[Bleep] crazy
that I have to persuade you
to take them down.
-Ah.
-Please welcome back to the show
Rosie Perez, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome back to the show!
How are you?
-I'm good.
I'm only wearing one Spanx,
so I'm good.
I can breathe.
-When you -- So, at two Spanx,
you have trouble
with your just respiratory?
-Yes. Yes.
-Hey, so, you are --
you're a New Yorker.
-Yep.
-You're an actor,
you're a choreographer,
you're an activist.
-I was a choreographer.
-You was. You're no longer.
-I got arthritis now.
-Okay.
-In my knees, in my hips.
I got a broken toe.
-Do you think that all came from
your young life as a dancer?
-Absolutely.
I mean, you know,
I was dancing hip-hop,
you know, on concrete.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then, when I was
on "Soul Train,"
I'm dancing in high heels,
jumping up and down
like an idiot,
having the time of my life,
and now I'm paying for it.
So yeah.
-I guess it's true,
what you're putting yourself
through is no different
than what an athlete
would put themselves through?
-Absolutely. Absolutely.
But I still dance in my house.
-You do?
Do you have, like,
the thickest carpet in the world
to make up for it?
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, because sometimes
when I fall,
my husband, he just
bursts out laughing.
-Does he like watching?
Is he happy when you dance?
-Yeah.
-Alright, good.
I mean I would be.
-I mean, of course.
-When you danced on concrete,
what were your early days of
hip-hop dancing?
Where were you doing it?
-Just, like, illegal nightclubs.
Ooh, can I say that?
-Yeah.
-Okay.
-I mean, I'm assuming
they're not going to file
a grievance against them now.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-Statute of limitations
probably went through.
So, where were
the illegal nightclubs?
-Oh, it was...
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, now you're clamming up,
Miss Perez.
I don't know...
[ Laughter ]
-Um, well, there was this
pop-up nightclub
called Car Wash.
-Okay.
-And, yeah,
so, they would just --
Sometimes it would be
an abandoned warehouse.
in a trucking service
where they shouldn't have been.
-So you would come in
as a sort of entertainment
over the course of the night,
to dance the hip-hop?
-What?
[ Laughter ]
I wasn't the entertainment
for the night.
-Oh, you were just
dancing to be part --
-I was just dancing.
And also, at that time,
I was working for...
[ Laughter ]
-By the way, when you said
you were dancing
at an abandoned truck
or whatever,
I wasn't like, "What?!"
I just went with it.
I don't even know
what you're talking about.
A trucking what?
Like a trucking depot?
Like a weigh station
off the highway?
What the -- Just rolled with it.
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I'm not gonna
call out Rosie."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh. Oh, man.
No, I would go there to see --
I was also working
at "In Living Color"
during that time.
Not only with the Fly Girls,
I had to do the dance,
but I also booked
the musical acts.
So I would go
to these nightclubs
to see what was the hot thing.
And I would have to predict
what was hot
before their record
would come out,
because, you know,
there's a delay.
And so I would see, you know,
Leaders of the New School,
and that's where Busta Rhymes
came from,
the Wu-Tang Clan.
Oh, my God, I remember
when I met Ol' Dirty Bastard,
he licked my hand.
It was so disgusting.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
-Aptly named.
[ Laughter ]
-So, stuff like that.
So it was --
-And was that something
that they -- I mean,
they must have had
a lot of faith
in your ability to see talent,
when you went back and said,
"Hey, these Wu-Tang Clan,
we got to have them."
Did they just sort of
take your word for it?
-They said no to Wu-Tang.
They were a little too hardcore.
-Yeah, well, I get it. For TV --
-Yeah, for TV.
-Back then especially,
they were very...
Is it amazing to you now,
like, as somebody
who was dancing in that era,
that dance on the apps,
like TikTok,
has become so modern
because kids are watching
each other dance
and learning new dance moves?
Do you ever look
at dancing on TikTok?
-Um, yes, because my sister,
Carmen, sends me TikTok videos
all throughout the day.
It's very irritating.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-And you know,
some of them are asinine,
but when it comes to
the dancing ones, I love them.
I just love 'em.
-Oh, that's good.
-Yeah. There's these two
older couples on TikTok.
I think they're --
they're Latino,
but I don't know if they're
Dominican or Puerto Rican
or Cuban, but
they're one of those things.
And they -- they hump
on each other,
and they're senior citizens.
Have you seen it?
It's amazing. It's amazing.
-What age are we talking about,
these people?
-I'm talking like 90.
-And they're
humping on each other?
-And they're humping
on each other.
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah. It's great.
-That's great. Good for them.
-Yeah.
-You know, if I'm 90 and
I'm humping on somebody,
I'm gonna put it online.
[ Laughter ]
I want everybody to see it.
You also -- You didn't just --
-Sorry, that image
of you humping.
-What's wrong?
It's not laughable.
It's sexy.
-Okay. Sorry.
-You should be going,
"Ooh, ooh."
[ Laughter ]
Wait. You also ran a club
back in the day, right?
-I did.
-How'd it go?
-It was horrible.
-Why?
-Because I -- I thought
it was a genius idea.
It was me and
my friend Bobbito Garcia.
You know Bobbito?
-Yeah, well.
-Who -- You do?
-No, I don't know
Bobbito Garcia.
[ Laughter ]
Was he ever with a guy wearing
a plaid shirt like this?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, he -- That's when he
went by Bobbito the Barber,
but now he goes by Bobbito
Kool Bob Love Cucumber Slice.
-Okay.
-So [Laughs] we were friends,
and he and this girl are like,
"Do you want to
do a club together?"
And I go, "Okay.
Oh, what should we name it?"
I go, "Let's call it love.
And how are we going to get
people to come?"
Because everyone knew
Bobbito Garcia,
and they knew me.
And so I said, "What if we say,
before 9:00, you could
get in for free
if you make out,
like tongue make out,
at the door?"
-So you make out
in front of the bouncer,
and then he lets you in?
-Yes, before 9:00.
There was a line down the block
at 7:00 p.m.
[ Laughter ]
We made no money.
-Uh-huh.
-At all.
The other partner,
she was so pissed at me.
And then it was packed, right?
We probably made like $1,000.
That's it.
And the rent was $3,000.
-[ Laughs ]
-And then somebody
called the fire department.
The fire department
gave us a fine, shut us down,
so we were in the hole.
It was -- It was terrible,
but it was great fun!
-For one night?
-For one night,
it was off the hook.
It was really great fun, yeah.
-So it sounds like maybe
good at parties,
bad at business.
-Yes. Yes, yes.
-Hey, I want to ask you this.
A lot of people, especially
during the pandemic,
were saying,
"New York is over.
This is never gonna come back
as a great city."
How did you feel
during that time,
when sort of this city,
during the pandemic,
emptied out?
-I thought that they weren't
real New Yorkers.
-The people who left?
There you go.
-Yes.
Thank you very much for
that one person that clapped.
[ Laughter ]
Up on top, I see you. Holla.
Yeah, because it's like,
you know, during 9/11,
people were leaving.
I stayed, you know.
It's, like, we got to support
our city.
And when the pandemic hit,
you know,
we could have went
to Connecticut.
We could have went
Upstate New York or Jersey
to my daughter-in-law's house.
And I said,
"No, we're gonna stick this out.
We're gonna stick it out."
So, yeah.
-Well, the city is lucky
to have you,
and it has been
for a long time.
You -- This show --
wonderful show,
you're working
with Bryan Cranston.
You filmed it
down in New Orleans.
-Yeah.
-Did you enjoy your time
in New Orleans?
Did you go and sightsee?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Not a sightseer in general?
-No, no, no.
Actually, the only time
that I ever enjoyed sightseeing
is when I was on
"The Flight Attendant,"
and we went to Iceland.
-Uh-huh.
-That was amazing.
-Iceland's amazing?
-Yeah, because I like the cold,
and that's why New Orleans,
I didn't leave the hotel.
-Too hot?
-Too hot.
I don't like the hot.
I don't like the heat.
I don't like
being hot and sweaty.
My hair goes poof.
It's just not a good look
for me, you know.
But the people there were nice.
-Okay, so, you liked
the people of New Orleans.
You just didn't
care for the heat.
-I didn't care for the heat
at all.
It's muggy. It's terrible.
I remember, during one day
we were shooting,
it was so hot,
I ripped off my Spanx
right there on-set.
I couldn't take it.
It was too -- It was horrible.
[ Laughter ]
-You work with Bryan Cranston
on this.
You play a prosecutor.
-Yes.
-Were you excited
to play a prosecutor?
-Yes, I was, I was.
-That's good.
-I know a lot of D.A.s
and assistant D.A.s,
and a lot of law enforcement
are in my family.
My daughter-in-law
is in law enforcement.
You know, I just --
I just love it.
I loved it, and I really --
I really relied on them
to create this character.
And I only had two days
to create the character.
I got a call on Friday,
had a shoot on Sunday or Monday.
It was -- It was nerve-racking,
And so I was on the phone
on the way to the airport with
my daughter-in-law,
with my two assistant D.A.s.
I don't want to
name their names.
You know, and even when --
right before set,
I'm just making notes and, like,
being all, like, nervous.
And when I got there,
I sat down.
I was a nervous wreck,
and I just --
I just let her come out, Olivia,
and she came out,
like, really pretty badass.
And so I got a call
when it premiered last night.
They were like, "You did good."
-Alright.
-Like, "Yay!"
-Well, I agree. I second that.
And may I just say I find you
pretty badass in real life,
as well.
It is so nice having you back.
-Thank you.
-Please come back soon.
You guys, give it up
for Rosie Perez.
[ Cheers and applause ]
New episodes of "Your Honor"
debut Fridays on streaming
and on demand,
and airs Sunday nights
on Showtime.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night.""